you say you didn't say it and then you
back away and I want to
say I'm not done yet Chris Christie then
just uh went after rebec just right
after that okay you say this you do this
you do this at every debate you go out
on the stum and you say something all of
us see it on video we confront you out
on the debate stage you say you didn't
say it and then you back away and I want
to say exactly what I said I'm not done
yet well this is now look this is man is
Ste nonsense let me tell you something
this is the fourth debate the fourth
debate that you would be voted in the
first 20 minutes as the most obnoxious
blow hard in America so shut up for a
while I'm I'm going to respond to
that I want to say something else we're
now 25 minutes into this debate and he
has insulted Nikki Haley's basic
intelligence not her positions her basic
intelligence she doesn't know regions
she wouldn't be able to find something
on a map that his three-year-old could
find look if you want to disagree on
issues that's fine and Nikki and I
disagree on some issues but I'll tell
you this I've known her for 12 years
which is longer than he's even started
to vote in a Republican
primary and while we disagree about some
issues and we disagree about who should
be president the United States what we
don't disagree on is this is a small
hard accomplished women you should stop
insulting so I'm going to take this I'm
several times over so first of all I
think we just learned something from
chis all right I don't want to spend too
much time on all this because you guys
know this is all a sideshow these are
not people who are going to be president
uh at all right but there were a couple
interesting things there the 12year line
was kind of good the way he hit VC on
that uh but the thing about christe sort
of being like don't insult her
intelligence well I will give BC credit
it was a good line it was a good line
name some provinces you want to send all
this money out there name some Pro
that's not going after her intelligence
that's going after her competency or
basically her understanding of this
region of the world that they want to
give hundreds of millions if not
billions of dollars to uh so okay we're
just we're almost through the the drama
here's uh just one more with a little a
little Zinger first of all Chris
Christie also doesn't know what
provinces in eastern Ukraine he actually
want us to fight for Chris your version
of foreign policy experience was closing
a bridge from New Jersey to New York so
do everybody a favor just walk yourself
off that stage enjoy a nice meal and get
the hell out of this race when it comes
to ni okay Zing he's fat we get it
fine